[Musique]
le super héros c'est plutôt de gauche ou
de droite ah oui tu veux faire le jeu du
clivage ouais alors des mecs qui se font
auto justice est plutôt de droite
on attend la plupart ils disent quand
même que c'est pour défendre nos prix
mais plutôt éventuellement un truc de
gauche façon suivant les auteurs et les
périodes ça change vachement les super
héros ils ont tous été pris en charge
par plein d'auteurs différents mais par
contre il ya un ya un historien williams
blanc quelle fin à luc sur la dimension
politique des super héros je crois ce
qu'on peut trouver des réponses
est-ce que c'est pas un peu trop de
nuances pour le jeu du clivage quand
même déjà faut poser le contexte les
super héros nous viennent des comics
américains
bon alors si ces américains c'est quand
même plutôt de droite on va pas se
mentir et a pas tellement de gauche aux
états unis no way c'est un peu la
mauvaise foi allons un peu plus dans les
nuances
à la base les comics et publié par des
petits éditeurs indépendants en grande
partie issues de l'immigration récente
et c'est un produit plutôt bon marché
donc accessible aux catégories
populaires et ça peut-être que c'est un
peu plus de gauche ensuite au fur et à
mesure ça se répand dans de nombreux
médias pour aujourd'hui rapporter
plusieurs milliards de dollars chaque
année
donc ceux de droite ce grand succès des
super héros est en grande partie due à
la mythologique qui les entourent que
william blanc qualifie de sorte de méta
mythe typiquement américain qui recoupe
à la fois des légendes contemporaine de
la mythologie plus anciennes gréco
romaine ou encore arthur yale et des
idéologies modernes en vogue aux états
unis à ce moment là ainsi à leurs débuts
les super héros sont l'incarnation d'une
foi en un futur meilleur grâce aux
progrès hérité du 19e siècle mais
toujours contre balancer cependant par
la peur de voir le monde démocratique
s'effondrer ainsi à la fin des années 30
les auteurs de comics qui pour beaucoup
viennent de milieux défavorisés
utilisent les comics pour leurs
revendications d'autant plus que ces
médiums relève d'un art populaire
méprisées par les élites et adressée aux
masses urbaines avec dans les premières
années une vraie liberté d'expression
enfin jusqu aux années 50 on va y
revenir
la plupart des éditeurs des premiers
comics sont des enfants d'immigrés juifs
venus da
magne ou de russie très présent dans les
courants progressistes et
révolutionnaires dont beaucoup adhère au
parti de gauche des états unis et aux
syndicats ouvriers
ce qui nous amène à parler de notre
premier cas probablement celui qui vient
en premier à l'esprit lorsqu'on parle de
super héros superman
évidemment je vous entends des joueurs
du village
ouais là on est faux que sur les
super-héros enfin accès sûr et du coup
superman de gauche de droite ou de
gauche
[Musique]
il a donc été créée en 1938 par deux
jeunes auteurs juifs
jodie foster et jerry siegel qui lui
font endosser l'espoir d'un avenir
meilleur comparé au présent sombre de
l'occident en pleine crise économique
est montée du fascisme dans leur
histoire l'amérique est une société en
retard et c'est superman
en arrivant sur terre qui va apporter un
nouveau degré de civilisation
sauf que ça bah c'est un discours
totalement à contre-courant de ce qui
circule dans les médias dominants au
milieu des années 30
les strips diffusé dans la grande presse
montre alors plutôt des personnages
sudiste symbole du colonialisme qui
apportent leurs marques civilisatrice
sur d'autres planètes extra terrestres
tels buck rogers ou flash gordon
ce n'est donc pas anodin de présenter le
pays comme relativement retardé et ayant
besoin d'évoluer plutôt que comme celui
qui apporte la civilisation ailleurs les
auteurs soulignent dans leur histoire la
montée inquiétante des militarisme et
superman surnommé l'homme de demain et
l'espoir d'un monde sans guerre sa
première livraison raconte une histoire
où il impose une trêve entre deux
dictateurs se faisant la guerre poussé
par un vendeur d'armes de washington en
février 1940 dans les pages du magazine
look il recommence mais avec hitler et
staline dont klaus entre qua non non ça
c'est pas les règles déjà le centre
n'existe pas un jeu du clivage en fêtant
cette utopie d'un pacificateur de
l'ordre international et régulières chez
lui comme lorsqu'il détruit l'arsenal
nucléaire soviétique et américain dans
le film superman 4 de quest for peace de
cela dit et sans surprise sa figure
évoluent en fonction des auteurs oui
logique mais aussi du contexte
géopolitique
lorsque la guerre froide est terminée on
lui fait aussi incarner les errements
des états unis devenu la seule puissance
mondiale mais se heurte pourtant à ses
limites en janvier 1999 paul dini et
alex ross dans leur album superman piece
of earth représente le super héros
luttant contre la faim dans le monde en
a pourtant lui-même de la nature aux
nécessiteux à l'image du messianisme
américain mais finalement cette action
provoque plus de problèmes qu'elle n'en
résout et superman comprend que sa
mission est vouée à l'échec
il reprend alors modestement son
identité de clark kent pour se contenter
d'enseigner à des enfants qui viennent
visiter la ferme de ses parents
comment cultiver des plantes l'homme du
futur des années 30 s'est pris dans la
gueule
le no future des années 70 pour une
prise de conscience d'eux
limite à l'image des états unis désabusé
suite à l'échec des interventions
américaines en bosnie somalie et irak
après le 11 septembre
alex ross point carrément le super héros
de dos levant les yeux vers une affiche
beaucoup plus vendre que lui
représentant les victimes des attentats
et les secouristes et lâchant un pauvre
petit wahou devant les héros ordinaires
qui triment dans l'actualité sombre que
la superpuissance américaine n'a pas pu
empêcher alors superman c'est de droite
ou de gauche voir ce clivage sans moi
par ici pas très sympa surtout que j'ai
un petit niveau
quyen thématiques ou super héros jean
batman de droite pas hésité si tranchée
oui c'est un riche héritier qui par
exemple dans le film de nolan 2012 the
dark knight rises combat entre autres
une coalition du sous prolétariat de la
ville qui veut détruire l'ordre social
ou bien sûr avec le film joker de 2019
qui fait de son pire ennemi le leader
des opprimés malgré lui certes mais
néanmoins batman c'est le super héros de
droite
dès sa création dans le détective comics
numéro 27 de mes 39 bob kane et bill
finger en effet l'expression des
craintes associées au prolétariat
c'est typiquement un personnage relevant
du stéréotype des gentlemen issus de
l'élite très en vogue dans les polars du
19e siècle se réclamant d'un style de
nouveaux chevaliers maintenant l'ordre
d'ailleurs c'est son surnom le dark
knight depuis le numéro un du comics
batman en 1940 c'est aussi un personnage
assez libertariens au dessus de la loi a
un car celle ci est corrompu à gotham
souvent pourchassés par la police mais
ils collaborent aussi régulièrement avec
elle comme avec le commissaire gordon
bref tout ça c'est peut-être plutôt de
droite mais batman c'est aussi robin et
on peut introduire une nuance un poil
progressed hills dans le personnage même
si c'est un tout petit poil évidemment
beaucoup de gens voient dans la relation
de batman et robin
un sous-texte homoérotique en
particulier dans les années 40 50
c'est vrai que les surhumain des comics
ne sont pas sans évoquer une esthétique
keim et l'image et des milieux gays avec
des costumes vie
coloré moulant à l'opposé des normes
vestimentaires masculine des années 50
le fait de se déguiser et de se masquer
peut aussi évoqué l'obligation pour les
homosexuels de cette époque de cacher
leur orientation sexuelle
bien sûr ceci n'est jamais explicite
mais a pu être lu ainsi par une
catégorie de la population en quête de
son identité sexuelle
ce que tout le monde ne voit pas d'un
bon oeil d'ailleurs le psychiatre
fredrik verte man qui n'aime vraiment
pas du tout les comics et considère
qu'il pervertissent la jeunesse publie
le livre de séduction of dit innocente
en 1954 où l'on peut lire je cite seule
une personne mais connaissant les
fondements de la psychiatrie et de la
psychopathologie sexuelle petit muret la
subtile atmosphère homo érotique qui
imprègne les aventures d'un batman
mature et de son jeune ami robin parfois
batman se retrouve au lit blessé et le
jeune robin est représentée assise à
côté de lui
ils vivent une vie idyllique chez eux
oulala et bien figurez vous que la
parole de ce monsieur a eu beaucoup de
poids en plus dans un contexte où la
peur du communisme
aux etats unis se double d'une obsession
homophobes qui met dans un gros panier à
salade le militantisme de gauche
l'athéisme et les pratiques sexuelles
qualifié d' anormal qu'ils vont anéantir
les fondements de la famille et donc la
société américaine et ça tellement
d'échos qu'on adopte le comics code
authority
ce dernier impose une censure aux
auteurs qui doivent bannir les relations
sexuelles illicites et les anormalités
sexuelle de leurs récits alors vite vite
il faut donner à superman ou à batman un
semblant de foyers dans la norme en 1955
ils se retrouvent tous les deux avec un
chien la norme qu'est et en 1956 arrive
dans detective comics numéro 2 133 passe
romane une partenaire platonique pour
bruce wayne
ce mouvement d'auto censure a marqué des
générations d'auteurs qui en ont parlé
plus tard à travers leurs créations
attention je vais vous décrire une scène
violente si vous n'avez pas envie de
l'entendre elle est directement à ce
time code dans l'univers de la série
watchmen en 86 87 à l'amour départ la
disparition de certains super héros dans
les années 50 en raison de leur
homosexualité
deux d'entre eux meurent dans des
circonstances troubles notamment
silhouette accusé d'être
homosexuel lorsque zack snyder adapte au
cinéma le comics d'alan moore
il décrit aussi cette homophobie
virulente des états unis d'après guerre
silhouette y est assassinée dans son lit
avec son amante alors que les mots put
lesbiennes ont été tracée sur le mur
avec leur sang oui car heureusement le
comics code a fini par être contournée
et puis par tomber en désuétude
malgré quelques tâtonnements dans les
under grande comics il faut quand même
attendre les années 80 pour que
l'homosexualité soit enfin évoqué alors
que le militantisme lgbt cuit plus se
fait connaître du grand public
c'est d'abord destiné à un public averti
exclusivement dans les boutiques
spécialisées on peut citer le roman
graphique camelot 3000 de maybach et
brian bolland édités entre 82 et 85
on y voit les chevaliers de la table
ronde serait incarné dans le futur et
dans des corps différents de leurs
précédents notamment tristan devient une
femme qui s'impose dans un groupe de
guerriers et se bat avec eux elle
retrouve son amour médiévale is hot
aussi réincarné en femme et après une
longue hésitation elle entame une
relation explicitement représenté dans
le numéro 12 en avril 1985
ceci ouvre la voie aux héroïnes
lesbiennes d'abord chez les éditeurs
indépendants
c'est le cas de l'héroïne sarah
rainmaker de l'équipe jane dont les
lectrices découvrent l'homosexualité
dans le comics jane 13 numéros 2 2 mai
les grands éditeurs suivent ensuite et
modifie certaines de leurs super héroïne
pour en faire des personnages
ouvertement gai c'est dans le comics 52
numéro 7 de juin 2006 que
l'homosexualité de batwoman est révélée
elle qui avait été créé à la base pour
donner à batman un semblant de relation
hétéro elle devient alors le porte
parole de la communauté lesbienne et son
succès est assuré puisqu'elle est dotée
de sa propre série de comics à partir de
septembre 2011
les super héros masculins gay ne sont
pas en reste comme on l'a vu dans un
premier temps ce n'est pas explicite
pour être de plus en plus assumé il ya
plusieurs exemples mais je vous cite
celui ci jean-paul bobier ayasse
northstar vega en français super héros
québécois membre de la division alpha et
c'est un personnage qui illustre bien
les stratégies utilisées dans les années
80 pour créer des super héros gay sont
l'affirmer ouvertement le scénariste
john payne bm je ne sais pas dès les
premiers numéros d'alpha flight à partir
août 1983 chez marvel laisse des indices
de son orientation sexuelle
il dira ensuite en interview qu'il avait
pensé en effet qu'il était temps qu'un
personnage gay voit le jour mais que le
contexte ne permettait pas encore de
faire de manière franche
lorsque bill main pleure reprend alpha
flight à partir de décembre 85
il va beaucoup plus loin dans les
alluvions par exemple au numéro 42 de
janvier 87 le super-héros contractent
une mystérieuse maladie qui évoque le
sida et dont il peine à se débarrasser
enfin aux numéros sont 6 2 mars 92 north
star peut enfin affirmer son
homosexualité
le numéro connaît un tel succès qui les
réimprimer alors qu'à la même époque des
auteurs de comics affirme publiquement
leur homosexualité tels philippe craig
russell en 91
enfin north star rejoint les x men et il
se marie à un ses compagnons au numéro
51 d'astonishing x men en septembre 2012
alors que le débat sur le mariage gay
fait rage aux états unis
bref aujourd'hui on trouve nombre de
super héros gay dans les comics pour
plaire à un public plus jeune et
sensible à ces questions on a atteint un
nouveau cran alors qu'ils arrivent aussi
dans les séries télévisées mais le
cinéma le médium le plus populaire et le
plus lucratif du genre est encore assez
à la traîne
bien sûr on ne parle ici que de
personnages homosexuels mais on a encore
beaucoup à faire pour la diversité
les personnages non bières par exemple
ne commence qu'à peine être évoquée dans
les comics tels lord fanni on était
parti tout comme ça aille batman bon
alors du coup batman c'est de droite ou
de gauche
batman serait proche
alors que wonder woman alors wonder
woman en fait ça dépend une meuf qui met
des raclées à des méchants c'est pas
censé être de gauche ça qui te tenue
pour exciter les mecs qui lille ça c'est
de gauche peut être vrai nom mais du
coup il vaut mieux répondre de deux
rouges comme pour batman
non mais tu peux pas dire ça enfin
batman et wonder woman c'est pas pareil
c'est pas si tranchée non plus
elle n'est pas la toute première super
héroïne lorsqu'elle est créé dans le
numéro 8 de all star comics en décembre
1941 mais elle s'impose très rapidement
son créateur et le docteur en
psychologie william moulton marston qui
s'est convaincu au cours de ses
recherches que l'avenir connaître à
l'imposition du matriarcat américain il
dit en février 1942 le futur appartient
à la femme les femmes dirigeront le
monde
il utilisera alors les comics pour
diffuser ses théories comme pour
superman on retrouve un personnage qui
vient d'une civilisation plus avancée
qui va faire progresser la mairie
cette civilisation elle vient de
paradise island à la technologie très
avancée en france est et missirah qui
est tiré de thémis tir qui est dans la
mythologie la capitale des amazones
justement le peuple de rondeur romaine
marston a conçu son personnage à
l'opposé des actions des hommes
commandés par leurs pulsions de
domination et de destructions les sommes
qu'elle affronte son demeurer ce qu'elle
veut soigner même par la force
wonder woman enferme ses adversaires
dans l'île de la réhabilitation pour
modifier leurs comportements violents et
les réintégrer plus tard dans la société
marston départ donc sa vision d'une
force féminine bienveillante pour une
auto pis matriarcale du tueur fut bon la
femme guerrière et forte qui combat des
hommes par la force
c'est plutôt de gauche mais la vision de
la femme qui veut les soigner et qui est
dans le care c'est encore une
répartition traditionnelle des rôles
mais bon c'est les années 40
c'est déjà un énorme truc de proposer
une fiction avec une société matriarcale
plus avancée que l'amérique ça s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans un contexte d'évolution
des mentalités peu après l'entrée en
guerre des etats-unis
les femmes ont leur propre ligue de
baseball professionnel pour compenser le
manque de joueurs masculins elles
occupent des postes qui étaient réservés
aux hommes partis au front
même si elle ne combattent pas elle-même
marston soutient ce mouvement et fait
même dira wonder romane rejoint les wac
et l'est waits et bats toi pour ton pays
c'est la période de la fameuse affiche
we can do it de jowhar myler en 1942 qui
plus est à partir du numéro 2 de sa
section comics en février 42 bombers
romane est accompagné par les hollies
degers qui ne sont pas du tout à l'image
des autres représentations féminines
typique des comics beaucoup plus de
leurs des pin up
elles elles ont des physiques variées et
elles vont à l'université wonder woman
elle même dans les premières années n'a
pas le physique plus peu propre à
assouvir les fantasmes masculins
cela dit il ya quand même une
contradiction dans le fait d'affirmer
qu'elle n'est pas faite pour être un
fantasme masculin puisque il ya quand
même un max de scènes de bondage
beaucoup de gens iront lui l'expression
des kings sexuelle de l'auteur william
blanc tempère un peu en disant que déjà
la symbolique médiéval avec les chaînes
etc
c'est très présent d'une manière
générale dans les comics ensuite c'est
souvent dans wonder woman les jeunes qui
sont attachés et qui sont libérés par
est donc on a plutôt une inversion du
cliché
il explique que marston et son entourage
ben aussi dans une culture féministes ou
envoient souvent utilisé la symbolique
de la femme se libèrent des chaînes de
la domination masculine dans les
affiches etc
donc ça a pu être une référence
graphique pour eux notamment le
dessinateur de la plupart des aventures
de wonder woman dans les années 40 à
ridge et peeters avait déjà illustré
dans les années 1910 de moderne one un
journal soutenant les suffrages east
américaine militant pour le droit de
vote des femmes
il était aussi proche de l'illustratrice
lourd rogers qui avait fait un dessin en
1912 qui s'appelait tearing of the bands
représentant une allégorie féministes se
défaisant des liens du sexisme
peter s'est inspiré de ce dessin pour
représenter la wonder woman qu'il fait
en 1943 arrachant les chaînes de la
domination masculine des discriminations
et du puritanisme les chaînes donc c'est
un motif qu'on retrouve aussi dans une
rubrique intitulée les wonder woman de
l'histoire supervisé par alice marble
championne de tennis et qui présente des
portraits de femmes qui ont lutté pour
la cause féminine
du coup les chaînes d'orange rondeurs
romane le fait qu'elle attache des
hommes était terrassé peut-être pas
juste une expression du clean de
l'auteur mais aussi une façon
d'illustrer ce que marc son appel le
l'autorité bienveillante des femmes
ah oui donc on est de retour dans le
caire louis lui totalement mais cela dit
pour l'époque
c'est les années 40 c'est déjà un truc
cool ouais et puis si tu regarde au delà
de norman en elle-même si tu regardes
qu'il a écrite
là c'est un peu un peu punk quoi à
l'époque qu'ils étaient marston l'auteur
il était en trouble avec deux femmes qui
étaient super féministe et du coup bah
elles ont forcément un peu influencé son
écriture sa façon de créer le personnage
et puis lui vivait vraiment à l'encontre
de toutes les normes de société de
l'époque la vision de la famille lui
cite pas pas la même chose que donc il
le vivait bien même si les universités
pour lesquelles vous voyez ça donc pas
très bon oeil qui s'est fait pas mal
virer des universités mais bon voilà
après il a fait des tas de revue qu'il a
il a inventé le détecteur de mensonges
marocaine voilà donc il travaillé
beaucoup sur les émotions et sur le sexe
féminin
la sexualité des femmes sexualité des
hommes accepta et donc ça transparaît un
peu mon dont l'oeuvre évidemment donc c
c'est un peu un peu de gauche engagé
quoi mais après par contre quand il est
mort ça a tout changé parce que la celle
qui était sa femme officielle qui était
mariée avec lui elle est allée voir
l'éditeur en essayant de reprendre le
flambeau pour continuer à écrire les
épisodes et tant mieux dit non madame
rentrez chez vous et on le fait à sa
mort en 47 tout ça ça a été bien mis à
mal avec la nouvelle équipe créative ou
en de romane devient déjà beaucoup plus
érotisée son nouvel auteur robert koenig
heurts ont fait une femme beaucoup plus
traditionnelles qui devient
successivement top model ou baby sitter
les hollies degers quant à elles
disparaissent progressivement tout comme
la rubrique wonder woman of l'historie
remplacés par des bandes dessinées
romantique avec des héroïnes qui cherche
l'amour mais c'est le coup de grâce avec
la publication du psychiatre
fredreik verte man dont on a déjà parlé
à ses yeux wonder woman est l'équivalent
lesbien de batman les femmes qui ne
construisent pas deux foyers et n'ont
pas de famille ni d'amour maternel
ça va pas du tout quitte à se contredire
parce que lorsque wonder woman adopte
une fille il interprète ça au contraire
comme des aspects lesbien le comics code
fini d'enfoncer le clou en exigeant que
les publications met l'accent sur la
valeur du foyer et sur le caractère
sacré du mariage et les images relevant
de la perversité sont interdites
ça porte un bon coup à wonder woman mais
elle revient en force à la fin des
années 60 avec la seconde vague
féministe et la période de libération
sexuelle pour devenir une égérie
émancipatrice on va la trouver luttant
contre les violences conjugales comme
dans la série wonder woman once in più
story en 98 dessiné par coline d'orane
scénarisé par trina robbins une
pionnière des comics underground
féministes des années 70 et qui a été la
première femme a officiellement dessiné
les aventures de l'héroïne en 1986 dans
les années 2000 le personnage évolue
avec les revendications féministes elles
ce sont vers de nouveaux sujets comme la
condition des femmes du tiers-monde et
le personnage peut aussi faire l'objet
de la critique des féministes par
exemple en octobre 2016 les nations
unies choisissent wonder woman comme
symbole d'une campagne
dial pour l'égalité des sexes ce qui
suscite un tollé et une pétition puisque
al'inverse de la façon dont son créateur
l'avait pensé wonder woman est trop
devenue une femme aux proportions
inhumaine en tenue sexy aux couleurs de
l'amérique
à tel point que l'onu retire sa campagne
et oui on n'est plus à l'époque de
marston où on pensait que les états unis
apporteraient un futur radieux
d'ailleurs le film de 2010 est dépeint
une grandeur romane tuant et détruisant
ce qu'elle considère comme ses ennemis
belle allégorie de l'interventionnisme
agressif américain et du coup on dort au
mas nallet de gauche ou de droite
bon y aurait encore énormément de choses
a dit aux deux super héros à traiter
pour parler de politique et comics
évidemment captain america qui fout une
torgnole à hitler dans sa première
apparition en 1941 ou black panthères le
premier super héros africains créent en
66 et encore bien d'autres choses
bref si vous voulez en savoir plus je
vous recommande évidemment la lecture de
l ouvrage de william blanc qui traite de
south en tout cas dans le fond on voit
bien que ça dépend des auteurs et des
périodes
évidemment en plus vous avez bien
compris qu'on fait de la mauvaise foi
assumée avec nos propres critères sont
pour sont subjectifs de ce que c'est la
droite et la gauche c'est pour la vanne
détendez-vous dans l'école c'est la fin
de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a
plu vous pouvez rajouter en commentaire
des idées de super héros et héroïnes
avec une dimension politique n'hésitez
pas on en discute d'ailleurs si vous
voulez en discute et on peut aussi se
retrouver sur le discorde du vortex
après les épisodes on peut être
débriefés ensemble et puis bien sûr bah
si c'est pas encore fait abonnez vous
pour ne rater aucune vidéo même si celle
ci était la meilleure je sais mais je
vous promets y en aura plein d'autres
des super bien et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine bonne phrase de gauche et du
coup la poutre de gauche de droite à la
poutre sait caresser droit série j cette
droite
[Musique]